Food is fun for many people, and this fits our nature because we need it to stay alive.
But what happens to you and your body if you stop completely eating
right Now? Translate AraSense initiative on Facebook
It is normal for the first six hours, as your body begins to break down glycogen,
Stored in the form of (glucose), which is used by the cells of the body as fuel. You go about 25% off
The energy of this process is to your brain alone, while the rest of the energy goes to the muscles
Tissues and red blood cells. But after six hours production stops,
And stores depletion (glycogen), which leads to nervous arousal or hunger and feeling
With anger that everyone knows well.
At this stage (6 to 72) hours, your body enters a condition called (hyper-ketone of the body), where fasting begins
Or starvation, because of the presence of small amounts of (glucose) in your blood, and starts your body
By disassembling stored fat for energy, these fats turn into fatty acids. However,
Your brain will not be able to use long fatty acid chains. This is a problem, because there is no more (glucose)
The fat is too large to cross the blood-brain barrier, and your brain starts to change your mood
Ketone molecules are used to produce energy, a short chain of fatty acids.
But it is a temporary solution, because 75% of the energy needed for the brain
Come from (ketones), we still need glucose! Which means that your cognitive performance will become
Poor.
You should know that you do not necessarily have to be hungry to enter the stage (hypertonemia in the body)
Most people enter this stage if they are following a low-calorie diet, or they are professional athletes
They use all their calories for long periods - such as marathon runners - for example
Will also include them.
But after 72 hours, your mood and energy will not only be affected,
Your brain will begin to break up the protein in your body, where the protein releases the amino acids
Which contains (glucose). This is good for your brain, but bad for your body.
In practice, your body will consume itself by destroying your muscle mass.
This happens when women because of malnutrition and menstrual cycle, the body tries here
That limits energy exchange. It also leads to osteoporosis, exposing both men and women to deficiency
In sexual desire.
Over several weeks, the immune system will weaken in the body without
Ie vitamins or minerals, leading to some deaths due to diseases. On the other hand, it will continue
Consuming all energy sources of fat, tissue and muscle mass until the glucose is fully depleted.
One of the most common causes of death is heart arrhythmias or heart attacks, due to
Deterioration of heart tissue, diaphragm and body. This is very common among sufferers
Anorexia. Of course, the organs of the body are experiencing severe deterioration at all levels.
Hunger can lead to death within a short period of three weeks to 70 days, as documented
During the "hunger strike" events in Ireland in 1981. However, the period of survival is affected
The extent of your body's moisture and the amount of fat stored in it, which
Sometimes his ability to endure for a long time without food, do not believe ..
To date, nearly 795 million people around the world should deal with this fact.
There is good news that the richest seven countries in the world have pledged to save 500 million people
Of malnutrition and hunger by 2030, but we must hold them accountable. We are working
Within an organization called the "global citizen", an easy way
Let you also help!
By subscribing to this video and going to the (global citizen) site you will be
Has joined your voice to an important educational movement that seeks to end hunger worldwide.
You can click on the screen or use the links. It will not take long
Only a few moments.
Subscribe to more weekly science videos